-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, Paul, it's Grammy weekend.
-It sure is Grammy weekend.
-It's a big deal.
It's a big --
What is your -- What is your
pick for song of the year?
-You know,
there are so many great songs.
First of all, Beyoncé did one of
the best records of all time!
-Yes! Yeah, they did.
Beyoncé's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sure.
-You think --
-I'm gonna let you finish.
-You think it's Beyoncé?
Ah, yeah, that was a good one.
-Taylor Swift, you know?
-Yeah.
-Did...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Could be that. Yeah.
-And I mean, it could be --
Bonnie -- even Bonnie Raitt --
-Yeah, she has a great one,
too, yeah.
-Isn't that wonderful?
[ Applause ]
-Mine is -- Mine is "As It Was,"
Harry Styles.
-Harry Styles.
-That's my --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Harry Styles, "As It Was,"
all the way.
That is Song of the Year
for me.
-That is amazing.
-Yes.
-Well, what is it that makes it
Song of the Year?
Why do you love it?
-It has a bit of everything
that I love in it.
It has -- it's almost
like it's filled with influences
from all my favorite artists.
Like, let --
I'll show you what I mean.
Can you give me a beat?
-I can absolutely
give you a beat.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that's it.
That's it.
The beginning is kind of like --
it's kind of like Bowie,
has a Bowie flow to it.
It's like...
[ Imitating David Bowie ]
♪ Holdin' me back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Gravity's holdin' me back ♪
♪ Said the man from space ♪
♪ With a lightning bolt
on his face ♪
[ Normal voice ]
And then it starts to really --
it starts to take off with
the lyrics there a little bit.
Now it kind of --
it sounds like Bob Dylan-like,
like very, very poetic
kind of -- it's like...
[ Imitating Bob Dylan ]
♪ Answer the phone ♪
♪ Harry, you're no good alone ♪
♪ Why are you sittin' at home
on the floor?
♪ What kind of pills
are you on? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] You know?
But then --
But then it's got this,
like, rapid-fire bridge
at the end
that goes really fast
that I love.
It's like riffing.
It's almost like --
kind of a little
Adam Sandler at one point.
It's like...
[ Imitating Adam Sandler
singing gibberish ]
[ Normal voice ]
It's kind of like that, but...
it also could be
kind of Mick Jagger-y, too,
'cause there's like --
it's almost like --
[ Imitating Mick Jagger ]
♪ Go home, get ahead ♪
♪ Light speed, Internet ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I don't wanna talk about it,
I don't wanna talk about it ♪
♪ Don't wanna talk about,
about the way that it was ♪
[ Normal voice ] But then --
then there's the chorus.
There's that chorus that just --
that sticks in your head,
you know?
And you start thinking
to yourself,
is it the same as it was?
[ Light laughter ]
You know?
It's very Springsteen almost.
♪♪
You know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Bruce Springsteen ]
"How you doing tonight?!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hey! Any Harry fans
out there tonight?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Ah, ah. Not that many.
Not that many."
[ Chuckles ]
"You know...when I was growing
up on the boardwalk..."
[ Laughter ]
"...in Jersey...
You know, we didn't have
social media.
You know,
we didn't have Twitter."
♪♪
-No!
-"No. We didn't have TikTok."
♪♪
"No, no.
We didn't have Instagram."
♪♪
"No, we didn't
have Instagram, no.
No, we had --
we had instant grandma."
[ Laughter ]
"We had a -- it was an old lady.
She would stand by the factory.
And we'd walk up to her,
and we'd describe
different things that we --
like a sunset or various
brunch items that we had.
We'd tell her that.
And she would say
that she didn't have
that type of brunch
when she was little, you know?
Or -- Or sunsets, you know?
But that's what it was like.
I'd say, 'Mary, is that
the same as it was?'"
[ Light laughter ]
"I said,
'Is that the same as it was?!'"
[ Audience cheers ]
"Is that the same as it was?!
One, two, three, four!"
♪♪
♪ You know
it's not the same as ♪
♪ You know ♪
♪ You know
it's not the same as ♪
♪ You know ♪
♪ You know
it's not the same as ♪
♪ You know ♪
♪ You know it's not the ♪
[ Normal voice ]
Catch me! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, yeah!
Hey, watch out!
Oh, hey, come on!
Be -- Be careful!
[ As Bruce Springsteen ]
♪ You know ♪
♪ You know it's not the same ♪
[ Laughs ]
-Ow, ow!
-♪ You know ♪
-Oh, my! Ow, let go!
-♪ You know it's... ♪
-That's my wig.
-♪ ...the same as ♪
♪ You know ♪
-Ow!
-♪ You know ♪
-Oh, my.
-♪ Same as it ♪
♪ You know, you know ♪
-Ow!
♪ You know it's not
the same as it was ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
Good luck to all the nominees.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hunh!
♪♪
♪ You know
it's not the same as ♪
♪ You know ♪
♪ You know
it's not the same as ♪